whether she was wingardium leviosa ing
doing awkward kissing scenes or getting
red cards for laughing left right and
center you can be sure it was never a
dull moment for emma watson on the harry
potter set we've got 12 of emma's best
behind the scenes moments coming right
now number one you do have to wait for
go oh the anticipation she had a dream
role a dream job we can't blame her for
being eager to get started
we have to see professor dumbledore
immediately number two but who's keeping
score well definitely emma
fierce feisty and ready to slay the
competition she will not lose let's take
a hot second to appreciate this little
queen showing all these boys what's what
all right rematch
this is a very good place
the pain goes on
i advise
number three time to get out the
measuring tapes
let's all take a second to remember how
important height was at that age
if all these young actors were going to
be working together so closely this was
key info they had to know i'm determined
to be taller than you
number four today's magical battle
features hermione granger and the
whomping willow can we all agree this
might be one of the coolest battles
watson gets to film this whole set is
almost like an amusement park ride and
emma was tall enough to take on this one
number five it started with a slap and
ended with a knuckle sandwich how
satisfying is this hit it gets us every
single time let that rage out
a classic hermione moment such a good
moment when i said slap me i was like
movie slapped me i'm not really sure
what i was thinking
number six run emma run but don't miss
out the chase the chase is awesome can
you say cardio it's okay you just start
running ready
hoping i had her fitbit on for this
sequence that's a whole lot of steps so
we went to this amazing forest and they
had this camera set up that i've never
seen before which is that it kind of
like runs on a wire this camera was so
bloody fast dan and i and rupert were
killing ourselves i mean killing
ourselves i've never run so hard in my
entire life number seven yes but that's
it no eating sitting or breathing too
hard in that dress i was absolutely
terrified i was going to rip it or spill
something on it or anything i got down
about three steps and fell down
in front of the whole set which was
incredibly embarrassing when she can
dance she will dance sure she felt
awkward and restricted but emma had a
classic magic trick up her sleeve fake
it till you make it i'm gonna come over
to the dark side number eight
one magical winter wonderland like
hogwarts coming right up
sorry but how are emma watts and under
co-stars meant to concentrate in a
perfect snowy castle this set looks like
a snow globe scene what does that do
with the scene
i'm good as gold i'm the class pet
number nine not such a teacher's pet
after this incident red card emma watson
just when you think she might stop
laughing you guessed it
she doesn't
they get fined when they giggle or if
they ruin a take how much is red cold
number 10 and today's real life magical
location is
it's nice to be away from leavesden and
to be as the usual kind of environment
happy to be here just another day in the
life of emma watson frolicking through
the scottish hills with two of her best
mates though she did suffer with the
whole being soaking wet in extremely
cold temperatures thing
number 11.
harry and hermione sitting in a tree
wait what they very easily could have
kissed that night do we want them to
kiss
it was a pretty opportune moment and oh
so sweet although watson did get a bit
more than she bargained for when they
were filming their ghostly makeout it
was weird he is a good kisser i i can i
can definitely vouch for that number 12
category is things that aren't on emma
watson's bucket list we did the case two
two weeks ago it was the most
horrible thing
we've been building up to this kiss for
a decade i was like how am i going to do
this justice the worst bit is when we
had to open our eyes and look at each
other because then i was just like
and then we couldn't keep awkward as it
was at least these two could laugh these
water soaked kisses off you know we did
it and uh it's kind of cute six takes
from her very first day to her very last
so many years later we pretty much just
fell in love with watson over and over
again and for all these memories to be
captured on film too sweet which was
your favorite bts moment